hey guys as you can see we've been
really busy since the last time you saw
us and on this episode of cabin land we
are literally going to raise the roof
I'm not saying going where's the roof
we're actually raising the roof
alright but you going Dorothee but we
are so it's not I mean we're literally
raising the last time you saw us we just
had a floor now we have all the walls up
[Music]
we have like almost half a house we've
got 18 walls since you were here last we
put a big old beam in in a second floor
for where our bedrooms gonna be so over
the next few days what you're gonna see
us doing is cutting the main trust
members of the roof system and then
building that roof system and then using
a forklift to lift them up off the
ground Lok those dangling through the
air and plop them on top and we're
building these on the ground versus up
there because it's easier
however it's using this forklift to get
these up onto the buildings doesn't work
we are in trouble because I'm really
nervous about this whole idea are they
going to break apart are they gonna fit
you don't know and it might not even be
safer just having a roof dangled from
before it's true I think they just drop
and crush us so before we do any of that
we actually have to build the roof the
first thing that we have to do is cut
all the members of the trusses the first
step of that process is actually taking
the intricate measures of every member
and creating a template so we don't have
to keep on measuring and marking over
and over again which is like half the
time okay we have everything cut and
measured now it is time to assemble the
roof ready to do this thing I am doing
this thing okay well awesome help you
this is the hub everything comes through
the hub all three rules are the same one
just a little bigger than the next and
basically it's a big old pyramid with
each face of the pyramid which is called
a hit it has a dormer coming out that's
a triangle pre-drilling is key so you
don't split the wood
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
who knows maybe I did cut it wrong I
might have cut it wrong I don't know
don't don't be so quick to deny my
ability to [ __ ] things up this is
usually for cars we're using it to lift
up a truss system I want to see he can
lift up the bottom
[Music]
nice no it's good
so we're gonna try and get some support
under it so we can fill the dormers on
it and make it level ish it doesn't
really matter it it's perfect because
this wasn't built on level ground
[Music]
well we got to use this table saw to
trim the bridge boards down to exactly
20 and a half inches throw a little bit
oversized and then pop em in
[Music]
so we're not gonna fasten these what
we're gonna do is we're gonna have the
guys ratchet strap these together so
that they're really tight and they hold
when we're bringing them into place and
then we're gonna fasten hopefully and
then we're gonna fasten them once they
get up there but right now that's real
good you can use it as a training
facility for your parkour yes I feel
good about it dear
yeah we know lift these up don't you
feel great about it yeah we're gonna
dangle them from 40 feet in the air
don't you feel like confident about that
no need to go up but I feel so like
exhilarated from just doing this but I'm
gonna just ride that out hope that goes
good tomorrow oh you do that enough
[Music]
okay today is the day that we raise the
roof we built all three trust systems
and now we're ready to load them up and
put them on top of the walls all hands
on deck for this we have Scotty your
brother Ethan our friend local friend
Raymond Ethan is putting braces two by
fours on the truss systems to kind of
keep it together and keep it from
busting apart
Raymond is hooking up the cables to the
tops of the trusses and getting them
ready to attach to the forklift we also
got Scott going around the tops of all
the walls of each of the structures and
trimming the plywood down so it's below
the top plate so this roof sits on it
nice and tight this is a really delicate
process if all goes right and hopefully
it does this could go really fast if it
goes wrong we could be looking at days
and days of more work and having to undo
everything we did on the ground we've
never actually seen a forklift be used
for this purpose it's a little weird
it's different but yeah exactly I had an
idea I kind of we're gonna MacGyver it
like this and hope hope that it all
works out
[Music]
we got ropes tied to the low-rise hips
the corners of each of the roof systems
Sara Ethan and Scott on the ropes kind
of keeping it steady while Raymond's
start to pork it into place and then
once it's getting close you're gonna see
me run up on top of this will you go
onto that rope
you can let go of that
[Music]
go slow let it steady let it go and stop
and go and stop and we'll just steady it
out every little time you know Scotty
get up on the other ladder but there you
are okay wait wait until you could stay
on the ladder we're good we're good Ram
it how extended are you can you just go
more so we could see if you can even get
that height wait wait wait
that's it max it out baby oh yeah that's
it look look at how look
oh that's above it that's above it
that's good that's good
okay you can bring it bring it down try
to Center it
[Music]
I think it'll I think it'll do it yeah
good just extend it out now you're over
the center I think one more foot keep it
out far it needs to come out another
half a foot that's it that's it
yeah come straight down yeah can you
push it it needs to come this way about
one inch down yeah that's it
you're getting to see it right now oh my
god I can't wait to see you oh my god
it's gonna be dope
dad's measurements were [ __ ] spot-on
bingo so now it's time for the big boy
now it's time for the big boy from up
there we were seeing it we could see
that it was like oh [ __ ] it's definitely
tall enough but the question is is he
gonna be able to close enough
considering he's on the corner here
[Music]
this end and I'll get the other end
freaking out I don't know what's gonna I
don't know if it's gonna bust apart into
a thousand little matchsticks or if the
lift is even gonna make it
you're trying to breathe take deep
breath oh we're almost there you're up
there the question is is it long enough
can you go any higher okay stop
here let's switch all right all right
stop bring it down stop bringing it down
we need another six inches too Scott yep
[Music]
selling like every morning yeah that's
it yeah yeah yeah yeah yes
[Applause]
two down one to go
that was the big boy this next one
should be like a cakewalk but we're
still taking it seriously because that's
when you [ __ ] up I love it
relief very stressful well we weren't
sure if we could get close enough if it
would go high enough if it would hold
luckily this is so [ __ ] tall you oh
my gosh we mean skyscrapers in the bar I
can't believe it
they're so cool I can't believe we got
that up there
Wow now it's now it's easy from here on
out just this little guy ain't no thang
see famous last words
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can you go up boy that's good
I want to spin it down spin it this way
right
[Music]
there you go right now
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
get your butt down and look at this okay
wait
put your hands over your eyes and I'm
going to lead you like what the [ __ ]
okay okay look at the way they're all
just like whoa I got a little girl in me
was very excited to know I was going to
be living it I don't believe in that
fairy tale [ __ ] but guess I'm not
your night shining armor Adi okay
[Music]
Raymond thank you appreciate it
high-five Scotty awesome today thank you
for everything thank you so glad that
you're here
ah all right let's make a fire and chill
now I mean that one
[Music]
that is it we have successfully
completed this part of the process yes
and I think that it went so smoothly
because of all the preparation all the
planning all everything we did to be
precise leading up to this point yes and
now we just have about 60% of the
project to go but then the glory work
begins the flooring the siding the
kitchen the tile everything we should
get to start making it like a livable
space and it really transforms after
this so very excited even though we have
a lot to do we should probably just take
advantage of this hot hot hot tub our
bones are aching
stick around we got lots more to do
let's go soak ok
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you